now an update on the story we brought
you last month a warning that at t and
verizon's latest 5g mobile service could
cause airline havoc tomorrow when it's
expected to go live across the u.s
airline executives claim that hundreds
of thousands of flights could be
grounded because of the technology that
can interfere with the plane's landing
instruments airports are already
stressed by winter weather pandemic
staff shortages and supply chain issues
errol barnett is at washington's reagan
national airport errol give us some good
news i feel like chicken little the sky
is falling
i know nate hey there good morning look
5g technology kicks in at airports
across the country tomorrow and airlines
are currently warning that interference
on its c-band spectrum could impact
close to half of commercial and cargo
flights now on sunday the faa made a
special approval for almost half of
commercial flights to operate at about
54 percent of airports across the
country with this technology and earlier
this month 18t and verizon delayed the
5g rollout to negotiate so-called buffer
zones around many airports still
airlines just don't think this is enough
they're warning that sensitive flight
instruments like autopilot and terrain
warning may be compromised in low
visibility conditions which we've seen
in the northeast this week they are
asking for lower 5g strength around 50
airports now att and verizon haven't
responded to airlines
raising the alarm about this in recent
days but these comms companies point to
the technology rolling out in 40 other
countries without any aviation issues so
they think things will be fine however
airlines are warning that they may need
to cut
many u.s bound international flight
scale beginning tomorrow
earl this is very very frightening to
all of us sitting here thank you so much
i just think when airlines raise a flag
and set and use words like catastrophic
people should pay attention to that
until it's all worked out because i
don't see why the airlines would
overstate this they want people on
planes
and now with the weather and also the
staff shortages i flew in last night and
you can see visibly that they are
struggling just to get through because
they don't have enough people that are
working at these gates it's very very
concerning